The sauce,
Kevin here and I'm auctioning off the ultra rare PlayStation five
Jake Roper prepared to cry. Addition to folks,
the frustration and heartbreak of Jake's fruitless attempts at securing
his very own PS five. With this addition,
your buying countless hours of entertainment and a monument to one
man's pain. I'm auctioning it.
Using a system of sealed bids.
The bidders submit their price and we determine a winner.
I've got four bids ready? Okay. Bid number one
day, co Jima. My great friend today.
OCO Jima who I met for nine seconds in 2013.
Even he can't get a PS five. Alright, well,
$400. That's pretty undervalued.
He must be a very patient and frugal man.
The PS five retails for four 99.
So if this bid wins Kajima is getting a serious
deal. Alright, bid number two, balloon. Kevin,
you are not real. Kevin. How many times I am real Kevin,
how did you even get in here? Well, whatever. And what is your pitch?
$3. $3. Okay.
Balloon Kevin is such a scammer. What a stupid bid,
but I guess maybe he thought that low balling was worth a shot. Whatever.
Moving on bid number three. Oh,
this bid is actually from Jake himself.
Still desperately trying to get a PS five,
550 bucks. That that's fair.
It's a 10% premium on top of the going price,
which makes sense for something in such high demand, smart bid Jake,
good luck. Hopefully we can dry those Roper tears.
And now to reveal the fourth and final bid drum.
Roll please.
Thousand dollars. Wow. That is, that is a serious bid.
Michael must really, really want this thing.
That is absolutely what you would call a pro
gamer move dramatically.
Outbidding everyone to secure the win.
And here's something that you don't realize is so genius about this.
This is not a normal auction. No,
this is a Vickery auction,
which means the winner doesn't pay the highest bid they paid the
second highest bidders bid. In this case,
that'd be Jake's $550. Sorry, Jake. You're,
uh,
you're really gonna want to stay hydrated because those tears will continue to
flow.
As Michael is playing his brand new P S five after only
paying your.
$550 Bin. So that's that. And as always,
thanks for watching. Wait, wait,
wait, wait.
A really, really aggressive bid worked out this time.
Yeah, but overbidding on a Vickery auction is actually a really,
really bad idea.
And virtually no one realizes that the most popular auction house in
human history works this way.
Here's the question. What are auctions?
The discipline of auction theory within economics is built on a handful of
basic auction formats.
You're probably used to auctions that start low and people bid back
and forth until there's only one bidder left.
The highest bid wins.
That's an English auction or an open bid ascending
auction. If you want to get technical,
you can also do auctions the other way as well.
A Dutch auction starts at a price.
Nobody would pay and descends until the first person bids and
their.
Buy wins instantly.
And there are two types of sealed bid auctions in a normal sealed bid
auction.
Everyone submits their secret bid and the highest one wins the end.
Then there's the Vickery auction,
a sealed bid auction in which the highest bidder actually pays the second
highest bid. But why would you do it that way?
Why not just keep it simple and how can such a tiny change in the
rules even make a difference? First,
it's important to note that we're dealing with an item with known value.
There's an established retail price for the PS five.
So we've got a pretty good sense of what it's worth.
Millions of people have paid that price.
Compare that to say a painting.
I might think it's a $100 painting, painting, collector, McGee,
the person I just made up. My think it's a $25,000 painting.
I don't know.
But what about if the item is like an oil field somewhere and no
one knows what's really underground,
that makes it tough to establish a value yourself,
but it makes it really hard to know what other people might be bidding
with a PS five.
We've got a pretty good idea of what other people might be thinking.
So let's say Jake figured he'd be up against someone who might bid
at least as much as the $550 he was willing to pay,
but maybe they'll try to get a deal and hope that everyone else can't
afford it.
He thinks they've got a bidding range of $450 to six
50 with an equal probability of submitting any bid within that range.
So should he bid five 50?
So that half the time he wins half the time he doesn't. And when he loses,
he's not really out anything in a standard sealed bid auction
format. No, if he bends over five 50 and wins,
he's losing value by paying more than he wanted to.
So that's out, but if he bids under five 50,
say five 30,
he'll still win 40% of the time against the mystery bitter.
And each time he wins, he's saving 20 bucks.
If the highest bid was over five 50, he would've lost. Anyway,
the extra value he gains out of saving $20, four times out of 10,
outweighs that one time he'd bid five 30 and lose to a bid
of five 50. That's called bid shading.
And it's what Nobel prize winner William Vickery solved in 1961 in
counter speculation, auctions and competitive sealed tenders.
Victories work on auctions included the development of the revenue equivalence
theorem, which showed that if an auction satisfies a handful of conditions,
the revenue for the seller will be the same,
no matter what the format and for all this,
he found out he won the 1996 Nobel prize in economics just
three days before he died.
So what's so great about Vickery auctions by
making the winner pay the second highest bid,
instead that incentive to manipulate the bidding
evaporated.
And it actually started to pay to be as honest as
possible. Vickery ushered in an era of honest bidding,
being the dominant strategy in an auction,
let's get back to Jake.
He wants to pay $550 for the PS five because that's what it's
worth to him.
If he commits to the pro gamer move of bidding eight grand,
just to guarantee that he'll win the auction.
The second highest bidder could be any number lower than that.
He could get stuck paying 600, 800,
$4,000 or more,
especially if someone else is trying to use the same strategy,
inflating his bid, not only doesn't help,
but could put him in a really bad position.
If Jake wants to try to save a little money, he can still bid $550.
If he wins, he's paying less than that. Anyway,
based on whatever the next highest bid is,
he doesn't have to engage in bid shading.
And if he does try to game the system,
he's susceptible to being outbid and losing in a second
price auction,
potential buyers also have a much harder time colluding with each other to
manipulate the price in their favor.
And sellers just don't have enough information to successfully
plant bids to drive up the price in a Vickery auction.
Jake's incentive to go higher or lower than his true value is just
gone. 550 bucks is his best bid,
but it's not just best for him.
Everyone he's bidding against has the same incentive to bid. Honestly, too.
The same forces are at work for them and they know it.
So why not just be honest?
The seller knows no one's trying to game the system either and they're going to
get the best price for their item. And guess what?
This is pretty much how eBay works.
Everyone submits their bid and the winner pays just a tiny bit more than the
second highest bid Vickery had no way to know that almost
60 years after his paper,
one single website on the internet would house nearly a billion and a half
auctions for everyday items worldwide and virtually
everyone would be able to use his bidding system from a device
in their pockets.
The 2020 Nobel prize in economics went to Robert B.
Wilson and Paul Milgrom for their work advancing auction theory.
And we've been thinking about a system where I have something you
want it,
and we need to figure out how to exchange it in a way that's best for both of us
for a really long time.
The Greek historian Heraclitus wrote about Babylonian auctions in
2,500 BC.
And that's the most surprising thing here in
4,500 years of thinking about auctions,
the mathematical development optimizing the activity of billions of people
is really close to just being honest.
And in the spirit of honesty,
I'm actually not auctioning off my PS five because I have demon souls to play.
And as always, thanks for watching real quick.
This video is sponsored by surf shark VPN,
use it on unlimited devices with one subscription to unlock streaming
services around the world. Watch Netflix in America.
If you're not in America, watch Hulu, BBC I player.
I don't know what you're trying to watch. And maybe I don't want to know.
Trying to watch,
but you could do it safely and securely by using surf shark VPN.
And I'm giving you 84% off and an extra four months
for free, which is.
It's amazing. Just use code V sauce too. I'm the sauce too.
If you use code Vsauce too,
then you get a great deal and you also let them know that I sent you and
everyone is happy. Don't you want everyone to be happy? Okay.
Go click the link down in the description below. Thank you to serve shrunk VPN.
They're sponsoring us to, I don't know why I'm doing this. Here we go.
I'm backing away. I'm backing away.
[Inaudible].